In this problem, a cyclone separator is
being evaluated for use in a mineral
processing facility. During design
review, the effective number of turns
inside the cyclone has been estimated as
NE= 4.8.
The cyclone dimensions and operating
conditions are listed below. The inlet
duct height is 0.45 m.
The inlet duct width is 0.2 m. The
cyclone body length L is unknown. The
cyclone cone length is 2.4 m. The gas
outlet diameter is 0.5 m. The dust
outlet diameter is 0.25 m. The gas
viscosity is 1.8 10 - 5 kg m* seconds.
and the particle density is 2100 kg per
me cubed. Assuming a standard cyclone
flow behavior, determine the cyclone
body length L in meters.
So, similar to last week's problem, this
is going to be another problem that is
fast and easy to solve as long as you
can effectively sort through the given
information.
Let's start by just searching the
reference manual for the term cyclone.
This will take us to chapter 2 for air.
Here there are two equations provided
that include the variable for effective
number of turns.
We are going to pick the first one under
cyclone effective number of terms
approximation.
The second equation under cyclone 50%
collection efficiency for particulate
diameter includes two terms that are not
given in the problem inlet velocity and
density of gas. So the equation for
cyclone effective number of terms
approximation is given as follows. N E
equ=
1 / H
* the quantity of LB +
LC / 2.
There are only four terms here and we
have three of them. They are NE for the
number of effective turns the gas makes
in the cyclone. This is given as 4.8 8
H for the cyclone inlet height in
meters.
This is going to be the inlet duct
height.
So H is going to be 0.45
m.
LB for the length of the cyclone body in
meters which is what we are being asked
to solve for.
And finally we have LC or the length of
the cyclone cone in meters. This is
going to be 2.4.
All of these other terms supplied by the
problem are not needed and are just
there to distract you.
So let's set this up and solve it.
We can simplify first by multiplying 4.8
8 by 0.45.
And that will get us to 2.16
m equals
LB + 2.4 / 2 is 1.2.
and then we subtract giving us an LB of
equal to
0.96
m which is our second answer over here.
So I based this problem on a similar one
from the NCES
but I realize it's very easy. The reason
I wanted to use it is to point you to a
new section of the reference manual that
we haven't covered yet and to show how
at first glance some problems can look
more complicated than they really are.
And that's it.
Like a psycho.